What's up, guys! It's Justine. Today we're gonna be making cake pops.
I've made them before.
And I've basically failed miserably
But today we're gonna be making them in this.
It's a cake pop maker.
I got it on Amazon, where I buy everything
And I thought this seems foolproof.
after doing a little bit of
research though most of the people
recommended not using boxed cakes with this
and when you make cake pops they're
cake, but they're also mixed with icing so
this is not going to be the traditional
cake pops that's smashed up cake with
smashed up icing. we're going to be
making a special concoction that is that
I don't even know I found this recipe
online so to be honest with you I have
no idea what I'm doing.
Huge shout out to Munchkin time
it's actually a super cute little website
this woman has her little daughter
baking everything. So I feel like if this
small child can do it pretty good chance I'm
probably going to fail at it but let's try
I mean what's the worst that can happen?
So we're going to follow her recipe, let's get all of our
ingredients we're making this thing from
scratch apparently the cake box
consistency is a little bit too thin and
it doesn't make your cake pops turn out
round I don't know a large mixing bowl
with butter sugar until light and creamy
okay well this is our butter it's
actually softened for once put you in
there we've got our sugar nicely labeled
cuz I've got a labeling machine and I
love it in you go
Honestly getting a mixer was the best
thing that I've ever done in my entire
life it does everything for me now watch
me mix now watch me nae nae let's turn it
up to 11
one two one two all righty you got to time it
perfectly
Ow! Ow!
mix flour with salt and baking powder
I like salt all right got our milk
Now let's add the other half I don't know why we do that
really this is our last step
Now watch me mix, until it's creaming
so far so good
let's taste it oh my sweet SwEeT batter
ooh. oh yeah that's good
so here's our little thing
So we're going to make the cake pops first and then we're
going to decorate them I guess that's
how it works I don't know how long I don't know
anything about this thing I do know we
need to spray it
cuz we don't want stuff getting stuck in here
okay so I was doing a little test
so that I wanted it to be perfect on my
first try that looks, that looks pretty done to me
I think we should get them out
I think we should get them out of here surprisingly
all I got to do is just peel that crap
away and we might have a pretty solid
cake pop on her hand the heck look how
good this is hold on it's really hot
it's so difficult to be like a little
test they look really good oh well gee
oh my god
my fingers are burning up my body is a
wild Wonderland by the Wunderland cheese
always ensues again basically when you
guys while you were away I just scooped
scoop into there just like it up so I
definitely put too much in that's for
sure
closer up
hey Google set a timer for five minutes
okay
five minutes, starting now
What's this taste like, good it tastes really good
well this insanity has been happening
I've been over here melting some
chocolate or some candy. oh boy I dropped
through treats a candy has been over
there melting and I've got this new one
that I wanted to try it's a pastel candy
melt with sprinkles in it I thought
since it's going to be st. Patrick's Day
and I don't even know like the soonish
that I would do some say Patrick's Day
themed cake pop people's good I'm
surprised I'm super impressed look at
this this is not nothing
oh yeah oh yeah they look good
Wow so hot we're so hot they're so hot
ah ah oh gosh burning so dumb you think
I've learned in the first one thanks
lamb super impressed look at our balls
look at this little thing it's a little
tiny cake pop tray I'm not sure if
that's actually going to hold up so
we're going to do a few of the white
cake pops first set a bunch of these
little cake pops popsicle sticks
probably should about shorter ones
piece of cake pop minis going to be a
little bit big but that's alright Duncan
here stick it in our cake pop dunk it in
it nice and covered nice and covered a
little bit chunky I think I'm going to
like let them sit a little bit come back
I with what's cooking and sliding off
the sticks looking good
this cake pop maker is incredible
and is it going to fall over and I'm
going to ruin all my cake pops and I'm
going to be severely enough happy named
by her today
oh yes we're going to have to look he's
falling off it's okay little guy I know
you've seen better days
Oh
This is kinda hard when some of them have
real crispy little corners here
and one last one for our collection
while here they. Happy St. Patrick's Day.
I'm pretty impressed there's a lot
of things that I could have done better
to improve them but overall I think they
look pretty fantastic so I want to taste
one because I gotta do a taste test
here we go it's actually really
incredible it was real close I'll help
you guys enjoy this video and to answer
your question and my question does the
mini cake pop maker work yes it works so
well I thought a bunch of other recipes
online for things that you can make in a
cake pop maker that aren't take top so I
can't wait to try some of those out
there's like little hotdogs there's all
kinds of things my life is changed
forever forever from the mini cake pop
maker you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you hit like so we can subscribe so
you'll see future videos and I will see
you in the next video there's also going
to be a little m screen that pops up
here very very shortly where you can
watch my previous video so check that
out too
yes later I'm going to order a pizza
right now I'm not going to touch my
phone I don't know if I get a
notification like what happens like
how's it going to nowhere just get my
pizza from we're going to try so ready
one two